after a a a few takes of a cigarette  you're already setting up  you know dependency if you will you do  it for four five six days in a row  you're going to feel withdraw instantly  this people know and understand but  again they're told that these  prescribed drugs by definition approved  by the regulatory agencies  they're they're different really but all  they're doing  the same way in the brain they all  interfere in one way or another  with the normal mechanisms this is stuff  that people need to know to take care of  themselves  take care of their bodies this is like  drinking clean water don't put into your  body  something that is going to dramatically  alter how your brain is working  because it's going to backfire don't do  it for very long at all  do it in protected circumstances do it  because you really know and they have  been informed beforehand  do it because you trust the person  that's recommending that  don't just do it because everybody else  is doing